As a general rule
of thumb, JavaScript
is not allowed to access
the data of any other origin
than its own.
An origin is made
up of three parts--
the data scheme, the
host name, and the port.
For the page you're on right
now, the scheme is HTTPS,
the host name is
www.udacity.com,
and the port is 443.
If you change any
of these parts,
you are on a different origin
and different rules will apply.
Apart from the mixed
content problems
we talked about earlier,
this is another reason
to not mix HTTP and HTTPS URLs.
But what are these rules that
apply once you are working
across multiple origins?
First of all, you can't
make fetch requests
to other origins.
Actually, under certain
criteria you can,
but then you can't
read the answer.
Secondly, you cannot inspect
IFrames or windows with
JavaScript if they are
from another origin.
These rules make a lot of
sense if you think about it.
Let's assume I was allowed
to make fetch requests
to other origins.
I could just set
up a website that
makes fetch requests to
facebook.com and steal
all your Facebook messages.
Or even worse, I could make
fetch requests to udacity.com
and make you drop out of
all of your Udacity classes.
No, we don't want that.
This restriction, or rule, is
called the same-origin policy.